[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and welcome
to episode 139 of the currently
daily Google Cloud
Platform Podcast.
We're here on the
show floor at Next.
And as always, I'm
here with Melanie.
How you doing, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK: Hi, Mark.
We are almost there.
MARK MANDEL: It's day three.
MELANIE WARRICK: Day three.
It's actually technically
the day after day three.
It's the next day.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, yes.
But some pretty amazing things.
MELANIE WARRICK:
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm doing OK.
I'm still soldiering on.
MELANIE WARRICK:
You're pushing through.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, today
was pretty amazing.
Today was the developer keynote.
A lot of our teammates
were on stage,
[INAUDIBLE],, Aja, [INAUDIBLE],,
Kelsey, just killing it.
Just killing it.
MELANIE WARRICK: All the things
you can do as a developer.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, you
should check out the keynote.
It was really, really cool.
They did some amazing stuff.
A lot of live code,
a lot of live code.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Which is wonderful.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know,
and Adam was saying, like,
let's show, not tell.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
yeah, it was a good day.
And we have a couple
more interviews
that we have done while
we've been at Next that we're
going to showcase now.
So let's go ahead and do that.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do it.
MELANIE WARRICK: We
have joining with us
Stephanie Cueto
and Vivian San who
are both here from Techtonica.
Thank you both for
joining us today.
STEPHANIE CUETO: Thank
you for inviting us.
VIVIAN SAN: Thank
you for having us.
MELANIE WARRICK: So tell us a
little bit about who you are
and what you doing.
STEPHANIE CUETO: My
name is Stephanie Cueto.
I was born and raised
in Southern California,
moved up here after college,
because I lived in the suburbs
and didn't really like it.
It's not very
exciting sometimes.
And I wanted to be
independent, grew up by myself.
And so moved out here
when I started college.
After college, was in
the nonprofit sector
for a little bit.
And then code kept bugging
me a little bit, and then--
it kept bugging me, actually,
all my undergrad, and then
after college too.
And then I applied to
a couple of programs
because I was like,
ooh, I like this.
And so ended up applying to
Techtonica, and now I'm here.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: And Vivian.
VIVIAN SAN: My name is Vivian,
and I'm a San Francisco native.
And I grew up in the
Tenderloin District,
so it was pretty much
heart of like the tech
hub and everything.
And I honestly had never even
thought about going into tech.
I was a chemistry
graduate from UC Davis.
And of course, if I spent
four years of college getting
a degree, I'm going
to come out of it
and be like, I'm totally
going to be a chemist.
There's no way.
But I mean it's weird how I
even came upon being in tech,
because it's something that
I never even thought of,
or something that anyone
even introduced to me.
But it was weird, because
the day that I came out,
I actually saw a
Techtonica flyer,
and I was like, you know what,
I'm going to give this a shot.
If I could do something as scary
as that, then I could do this.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And for those who
don't know, what is Techtonica?
VIVIAN SAN: So
Techtonica is basically
a nonprofit organization
that is providing
free technical training to local
woman and non-binary adults,
and basically just giving
them the opportunity
to learn these
relevant tech skills,
and without having to
worry about the cost of it.
And especially if
they're mothers,
they don't have to
worry about childcare.
Just giving them a safe
place and work in a community
to just learn.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And my understanding
is you're both from
the first class, right?
VIVIAN SAN: Yeah.
STEPHANIE CUETO: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Wow,
that's amazing, awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
you just finished?
VIVIAN SAN: Yeah, last week.
MELANIE WARRICK: Last week.
STEPHANIE CUETO:
Yeah, everything's
going so fast, whoa.
VIVIAN SAN: I know.
MELANIE WARRICK:
It usually does.
Are you in the process now
of doing the whole preparing
and looking for jobs?
VIVIAN SAN: So
amazing thing that
happened is that Techtonica
was able to provide everyone
a placement with a partner.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
VIVIAN SAN: Yeah, so
we all have internships
starting either
next week on Monday
or a couple of weeks after that.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh, wow.
VIVIAN SAN: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So
it looks like they
provide tech apprenticeships.
Can you tell us about
what that looks like
and what you
actually end up doing
when you're in the program?
VIVIAN SAN: I would
say the first three
months is just really just
learning all about everything,
about JavaScript, like
learning it religiously.
No, but really just
the first three
months is just learning
the fundamentals really.
And then the next three months
is just doing all projects
and just building off
of what we learned
and being able to apply
it working in groups
and also working independently.
So just getting a little
bit of best of both worlds.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
And I know there's also support
for people with low incomes,
so they provide laptops,
things like that as well.
STEPHANIE CUETO: So they
provide-- if you need a laptop,
they provide a laptop.
If you need you need
some help financially,
they also provide a living
stipend for the apprentice.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
And where are you starting--
it's internships or it's--
where are you starting?
STEPHANIE CUETO: Internships.
So it's Mixpanel, so
a bit of a competitor
with Google Analytics.
MELANIE WARRICK: We
will accept that.
[LAUGHTER]
VIVIAN SAN: And I'm
starting at Redfin,
so they're a real
estate company.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah.
Awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Well, this is great.
So we're at Next.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: And you've
been here for two days.
It's like the third
day, as we speak.
How has it been?
What have you seen that
you've been excited about?
VIVIAN SAN: I think
this is literally
the biggest conference
we've ever been to,
because we're only so used to
just being in one building.
But this is spread out between
like five different places.
And it's pretty
crazy, but I mean,
it's just insane how much
technologies are out there,
and how much they're
releasing so quickly.
I mean, it's also really
overwhelming [INAUDIBLE]
but really exciting,
because you know,
especially now as
we're developers,
we know all these tools
that are out there.
And we know that we can
take what we learn from here
and be able to tell
our companies about it,
be able to leverage
our knowledge
and being able to contribute.
And I think that's really the
most amazing thing is just
being able to feel that way.
STEPHANIE CUETO:
Yeah, and I think also
just how welcoming it is too.
I think sometimes we take
for granted that we're
in San Francisco, and
then we meet other people
from other parts of the world
and they're like, oh, my gosh.
They're taking pictures.
And at least for me, I've
been to other conferences too.
And this is probably
one of the biggest ones
where it combines
a lot of people,
because it's like
developers, marketing, sales,
like all these people that
come from different backgrounds
in tech.
So it's pretty interesting
to just see the mesh of it.
But when we talk to them,
they're like, oh, my god.
You're from-- like
you live here.
And I'm like, yeah.
This is amazing.
You're like around everything.
And I'm like, yeah,
it's really cool.
So it's interesting just to
meet other diverse people
and just kind of get
the other perspective,
because sometimes I think
we do take for granted
that we're around here.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And I was asking you
before we started
that, were there
any sessions that you went to
that you were excited about?
Are there any sessions
that you wanted
to mention that you saw
and found very interesting?
STEPHANIE CUETO:
Yeah, so I was talking
about the #IamRemarkable
workshop that's
happening upstairs in the
second forum, Moscone West.
And it was just very--
I came in that it just kind
of like, oh, it sounds cool.
Let me see what it's all about.
And then they came at you
with stats, they're like,
hey, your remark was-- so
it's a workshop targeted
towards women, but
it's also for everyone.
It's just kind of like
change your mindset
of how you think about
yourself, because with women
specifically, they are
more prone to be put down
by both men and women.
So if they ever are
bragging about themselves
when they say their
accomplishments out loud,
or if they speak up,
or anything like that,
they're more likely to be,
she's talking too much,
or she's like bragging
about herself, or anything.
So you're getting hit not
only from the male side of it,
but also your own
colleagues that are women.
And then on top of
that, we also are
more prone to talk bad
about ourselves too.
We don't want to
come off that way,
so then we start putting
our own selves down.
Like, oh, we shouldn't
probably shine that much,
and just put our accomplishments
a little bit down.
So they gave us a
good background on it
and just where these
stats were coming from.
And then after that, we
did the actual workshop
where they gave us a
piece of paper where
you write down all
the things that you're
remarkable because of.
So it was interesting just to
see like how people get stumped
and how people were
also very positive on.
So they were able to
write the whole page down
to say I'm remarkable because
I'm a software engineer.
I'm remarkable because I speak
two languages, three languages,
or four languages.
I'm remarkable because I
volunteer all my spare time
here.
And just all these things that
come out that you don't really
realize that you're
doing, and that you
are remarkable because.
And so some people were
going really strong
and some people were like
stumped at one point,
because we just--
I guess we're prone to
not-- like they were saying,
we're not prone to
really think that way.
And we need to change
that, look in the mirror,
be self-positive, talk
to yourself and say,
you are remarkable.
Yeah, you're beautiful,
you're positive.
No, you're an amazing person,
and change that perspective
a little bit, or more.
And so it was just amazing.
I was almost able to write
that whole page at the end,
but kind of fell short.
But it's OK.
I'm going to try to do it.
And it's a good thing to do when
you go to your teams and stuff
like that.
And even your
friends, make everyone
change their perspective
of how awesome they are.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Vivian, any sessions
that stood out for you?
VIVIAN SAN: Yeah, I mean that
one for sure was one of them
too.
We also went to
one where they were
talking about accessibility
and inclusion.
And I thought that
was really awesome,
because just like you don't--
especially when you're making
docs or making meetings,
that's not something
that you purposely
try to do and not make
it inclusive for all
your employees, but it's just
something that does happen.
But it's like I found
it so amazing how
there was so much
detail that goes
into it to try to make
everyone feel safe
and make everyone feel included.
And I felt, especially for us,
it's like what we were told.
When we come into
this, we can learn
all the technical knowledge
that people will tell us
and we can learn it
online and stuff,
but you can't really
teach people perspective.
And I think for us,
especially, coming in
from non-technical background
and low income families
and communities, I
think that showed us
that we could contribute.
And I felt like just
because of that talk,
it made me feel more comfortable
going and saying yes,
I can make a
contribution, that I could
be a strength to this company.
And I thought that was amazing
just to hear them say that.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Have you played with any
of the showcase demos
or anything else
around here as well?
VIVIAN SAN: Not yet.
STEPHANIE CUETO: Not yet.
But we're going to today.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
what's next for you.
STEPHANIE CUETO: Yeah.
We've been going to a lot
of the talks and everything,
walking around.
We haven't even gone to the--
I think there's a couple
workshops that I want
to go to today at the hotel.
So I went to one in the
Metreon, in the theater,
which was kind of interesting.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, cool.
STEPHANIE CUETO: And then
some of the hotels, there's--
huge, you know.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know,
when we-- actually,
before we started, too, we
were talking about how you were
surprised that there's so
much that Google has in terms
of products and services.
STEPHANIE CUETO: Yeah, I
didn't know it was like an AWS,
basically, like Amazon.
I was like, whoa,
you can do everything
that Amazon does too, like
hosting websites, doing
all these things.
I was like, whoa.
I didn't know all of this.
And I was amazed when I was
hearing the keynote speakers
speak about all of these
products that are coming out,
or they're revamping
and everything.
I was like, whoa.
I need to get on
Google even more.
MARK MANDEL: Good.
Our job here is done,
we can all go home.
MELANIE WARRICK: We're done now.
Last question I want
to ask you both is,
coming from this program,
is there any advice
that you have for those
who are getting into tech?
STEPHANIE CUETO: So at
the end of our last week,
Michelle made us--
Michelle, the CEO, she
made us reflect and write
down advice that you probably
have for future apprentices.
And I kind of
thought about myself,
and I was like,
what would I want
to hear in the beginning
of this program
to make it a little bit easier
and everything like that?
And so we did write
down a couple of things.
And one of those things to me
was, or to the future ones,
is like, hey, this is going
to be tough, so make sure
you do prepare.
Make sure you're strict
with your schedule.
You are going to have to
really focus right now.
You're going to have
to be frugal, too,
because it's a long process.
You're not working right now.
And so make sure that you're
very disciplined, one.
It's OK to say no.
It's OK to say no to other
activities, like birthdays,
like all these festivities.
They're going to be there
still the next year.
And so right now, you
need to focus on you.
And that was the one main
thing that I was like,
it's OK to say no.
And it's OK to focus on this.
And you need to be a
little bit selfish.
You just need to focus
on yourself right now.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
VIVIAN SAN: And I would
say it's OK to feel scared,
because I went into it
and I was so terrified.
I was like, I
don't know anything
and I don't know what to expect.
And everything was
just so unknown.
I think I would just tell
the future apprentices
that it's OK to feel scared.
And I think just allowing
yourself to feel vulnerable,
and the fact that
you do feel scared,
I think that's actually
a really good thing,
because it's telling
you that you're actually
trying to push yourself
to learn something new
and trying to change your life.
And I think that's OK.
Like you feel scared
might actually
be a good thing,
especially if there is--
more cohorts that are
coming in, I would tell them
that we need more women
and we need more diversity,
we need more inclusion.
And by doing this,
you are helping
to, I guess, as Michelle would
say, bridge the tech gap.
Essentially, just
being able to put more
perspectives out there.
And you are going
to be someone who's
going to be part of this
community to change the world.
STEPHANIE CUETO: I think
I would add on to--
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, please.
STEPHANIE CUETO:
--you are like--
we all became very close.
We're very strong.
And it's like make sure--
you are all going
through similar things,
reach out to one another,
speak to one another.
You're going to
go through a lot.
And so make sure you
have that support system,
because maybe your parents or
anyone doesn't really know what
you're going through right now.
It's a different background,
or maybe even friends.
So you guys are all going
to become very strong.
And make sure you keep
that together and rely
on one another.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Find your community.
Build your community.
And places like this, too,
give you the opportunity
to expand that too.
STEPHANIE CUETO: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Well, thank you very
much for joining us and
sharing your experiences.
We really appreciate it.
STEPHANIE CUETO:
Yeah, thank you guys.
It was pretty fun.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
Super excited.
We have two really amazing
people coming to join us today.
Liz-- and I don't
remember your last name.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Fong-Jones.
MARK MANDEL: Fong-Jones.
I had it right in my
head and I got it wrong.
Nikhita--
NIKHITA RAGHUNATH: Raghunath.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Thank you so much, both of
you, for joining us today.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank
you for joining, yes.
NIKHITA RAGHUNATH:
Thank you for having us.
MELANIE WARRICK: Granted,
grabbed you all off the floor
and was like, please,
please, come on the podcast.
MARK MANDEL: So you both
do very different things,
but Liz, why don't you tell
us a little bit about yourself
and tell us what
you do and stuff.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Sure.
So I am a Customer
Reliability Engineer,
and I help GCP customers build
and operate reliable services
on GCP.
So that involves anything
from teaching them
how to run incidents
to teaching them
how to manage their services
and how to architect
their services better.
MARK MANDEL: And we've
done a podcast with you
previously, too.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Yes, you have.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, we have.
Nikhita, what do you do?
NIKHITA RAGHUNATH:
So I work at Red Hat.
I am a Kubernetes
maintainer, and I
work on all things
extensibility of Kubernetes.
And Mark knows a lot
about that, I guess.
And yeah, I like to do
everything open source,
basically.
MARK MANDEL: Basically,
the work that you
do makes Agones possible,
which is awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
we like open source.
And we have an episode
coming out on Agones
in a couple weeks.
So Nikhita, what are
you enjoying about Next?
NIKHITA RAGHUNATH:
Oh, I love Next.
So I was visiting the
booths in the booth area,
and the most
interesting part was
looking at how everyone
is using Google Cloud.
And the one thing I noticed
is that almost all companies
are using GCP or GKE
in very different ways.
So I think it was pretty
cool going to all the booths
and figuring out how they're
using it and understanding more
about it.
MELANIE WARRICK: And then,
Liz, I know you just did a talk
and you're finally
free of the talk.
How was your talk?
What was your talk about?
LIZ FONG-JONES:
So yesterday I got
to share with everyone a bunch
of early access Stackdriver
features that enable people
to do their operations more
like SRE using
Stackdriver tooling.
So specifically, how do you
improve your measurement,
how do you improve your
time to detect incidents,
time respond to incidents,
using really cool stuff
that we're finally
getting to talk about?
So my favorite
thing about Next has
been getting to release
all this cool stuff
and see how people react to it.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's fantastic.
MARK MANDEL: That's really cool.
We talked a lot
about open source,
I think, pretty much
all over the place.
Nikhi, you've been
involved with open source
for a really long time.
How did you end up there?
NIKHITA RAGHUNATH: It's not
been a really long time.
It's like, a year, I guess.
MARK MANDEL: That's a long time.
NIKHITA RAGHUNATH:
Well, I just graduated,
so I got involved
through a program called
Google Summer of Code.
So it's that Google pays
students to work on open source
projects during the summer.
And I started contributing
to Kubernetes that way.
And well, I just
contribute a lot right now.
So that's my open
source journey.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Liz, what's your experience
with the open source world?
What are your perspectives in
terms of where things are at
and what you're excited about?
LIZ FONG-JONES: I'm really
excited that there is so much
interesting work happening
with the OpenCensus
with Kubernetes,
where we're starting
to see a lot of the things
that we've been doing inside
of Google for a long time be
accessible and interoperable
with people outside of Google.
That's been super
awesome, because it
means that people don't have
to reinvent the wheel over
and over.
They can just plug
it into things
that people have already built.
And that's really awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
NIKHITA RAGHUNATH: I
totally love OpenCensus.
I want to contribute
to it at some point.
Maybe I'll get to it after Next.
MELANIE WARRICK: We also
did a podcast on OpenCensus.
NIKHITA RAGHUNATH:
Oh, I'll check it out.
MARK MANDEL: I'm sure
you don't need it,
but if you need introductions,
I'm more than happy to--
NIKHITA RAGHUNATH: I
do need introductions.
I will definitely look it at.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARK MANDEL: That's really cool.
And I know you work on the
extension part of Kubernetes.
What are some cool
extensions that you've seen?
NIKHITA RAGHUNATH:
Oh, I think there's
something called Agones.
I think it's also covered
on the GCP podcast.
MARK MANDEL: It is a bit.
NIKHITA RAGHUNATH: Yeah, so you
should definitely check it out.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, anything
else, other than stuff I
work on?
NIKHITA RAGHUNATH: I
think operators are really
the kind of exciting bit
related to extensibility
of the Kubernetes API.
And I think there
are lots of operators
out there, so I think
I would definitely
say the operator bit.
MELANIE WARRICK: I love how
we're plugging all the things.
And let me also bring this back.
It's quite an interesting
intermix of discussion.
But Liz, I know we had you
on, like we said, with Seth.
And we talked about
SREs and DevOps.
And my understanding
is you guys just
had another episode
that came out
in terms of the video series
that you're working on.
Is that right?
LIZ FONG-JONES: We have a new
set of five episodes coming out
in late August.
MELANIE WARRICK: Ah,
so you have one coming.
LIZ FONG-JONES: We
recorded them last week.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
saw some announcement.
I thought it had already
come, but apparently not yet.
So it's coming out in
August-- in late August.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Late August.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
And any specific highlights
that you can mention now?
LIZ FONG-JONES: Yeah, we
have a really packed agenda.
We're talking about
things like how
do you respond to
incidents, or how
do you set up your alerting
so that you can actually
reasonably defend your
service level objectives,
rather than finding
out, hey, we broke it
but we didn't find out
until it was too late.
MARK MANDEL: Very nice.
OK, I know you both have to
go, you both have meetings.
Before you go, favorite thing
you've seen at Next so far.
NIKHITA RAGHUNATH: Agones.
MARK MANDEL: Awe.
NIKHITA RAGHUNATH: No,
it was really cool.
I loved your talk.
It was funny, so I liked that.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
I appreciate that.
Liz, favorite thing?
LIZ FONG-JONES: I have to say
the thing from this morning,
the mini TPUs, the Edge TPUs.
That was really exciting to
see that these chips of silicon
that Google's manufacturing will
be in a whole bunch of devices.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Well, thank you so much
for coming and taking
some time to chat with us.
We really appreciate it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Yeah,
thank you for having us.
NIKHITA RAGHUNATH: I just
came for the chocolate.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes,
we have chocolate.
Please have chocolate.
MARK MANDEL: Please
take the chocolate.
[INAUDIBLE]
So it's great that Robert
Kubis is joining us.
He is a fellow develop advocate
and alumni podcast attendee,
I think.
[INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT KUBIS: For
a week, I think.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's all you need.
MARK MANDEL: You've been
pretty busy here at Next.
What have you been up to?
ROBERT KUBIS: Yeah,
like first of all,
thank you for having me
again, like after a week,
at the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK:
You were that good.
We need to get you back.
ROBERT KUBIS: Maybe, maybe.
Yeah, it has been
really exciting.
So I think what
is maybe sometimes
not seen that there's a
lot of work that goes in
by the [? DA ?] team, or
general, like a lot of Google
teams into making this
conference a reality.
So I was involved personally in
building some of the showcases.
So in particular,
two of the showcases
that I was involved in,
the Cloud Spanner booths,
or showcase, I was involved
in the creatives, as well as
building part of the demos.
And for the storage and
database one as well.
And it's actually a lot of work.
You can't imagine.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah?
How many months of
work has it been?
MARK MANDEL: It's
the cloud, though.
Don't you just push a
button and make it work?
Like isn't it-- it's not like--
I just assume
that's all you need.
MELANIE WARRICK: You
just push a button.
MARK MANDEL: Just push a button
and it makes software happen.
MELANIE WARRICK: No code.
ROBERT KUBIS: So that's
actually a funny thing.
I think the majority
of work is not actually
the coding or the
technical part of this.
The majority of the
work is actually getting
the messaging right.
We want to have that the
attendee has a good experience,
that they understand
what we want
to achieve with the
showcase, that they
get an intrinsic experience
into the showcase.
And creating this kind of
narrative is most of the work,
I would have to say.
And then fine tuning it and
then getting it into reality
is the heavy lifting
for creating a showcase.
MARK MANDEL: So tell
us about the showcases
you had a hand in.
Tell us what those
are all about.
ROBERT KUBIS: So the first one
is the Cloud Spanner showcase,
where we have two
substations in that showcase.
So one of them is what we call
the Cloud Spanner Kaleidoscope,
which is a really cool
looking installation
with some mirrors, and a
display, and some buttons,
and handles, and wrenches, which
is the-- in British English,
it's actually-- spanner
is a wrench [INAUDIBLE]..
What we wanted to show
there is the aspect
of manageability
in Cloud Spanner,
that it's very easy to
get your own instance
and scaling it in and out.
And we wanted to show you
that it's done in four clicks.
And you basically
choose a name, you
choose what configuration
you want to have,
you want to choose how many
nodes you want to have,
and then you click OK and
you have your own instance.
So very easy.
So the substation two is where
I actually show how easily
and how quickly Cloud Spanner
is scaling in and out.
So I have a demo where you
can produce some throughput,
some reads and writes
against Cloud Spanner.
And then you can
scale it in and out,
or you can scale the nodes.
And you see how quickly
Spanner is load balancing,
and your latencies go down
again, and things like that.
It's a really cool thing.
I encourage everybody
to check it out.
MELANIE WARRICK: Cool.
Well, so what have you
seen at Next outside
of what you've been working
on that you're really
excited about?
ROBERT KUBIS: So
there's, unfortunately,
not a lot of things.
I also had two talks that
I had to prepare of and--
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh,
easy-peasy, right?
You just got it all
done very quickly.
MARK MANDEL: It's a
showcase and two talks.
I mean, like whatever.
It's fine.
ROBERT KUBIS: Exactly, exactly.
So the thing is, I guess
there a lot of people like me
in the sense, but most
people maybe not seeing that
from the outside.
But I'm a notorious
procrastinator.
So I'm probably the best in
my life in procrastinating
till the deadline is looming.
So I'm usually the one who is
late with slides and preparing
till late hours and
stuff like that.
MELANIE WARRICK:
No one does that.
ROBERT KUBIS: Exactly,
no one is doing that.
So I have pretty
much been involved
in preparing for my talks to
deliver a good experience also
to the attendees.
They are coming here
to get some information
and to get the best
out of the session,
so I want to give
them the best of me.
So I invested a lot of time
into perfecting my talks
and really have a good
experience for the attendees.
I got to walk a little
bit around the showcase
floor in Moscone West today.
And one experience
which I really liked
was the Cloud
Function experience--
MARK MANDEL: I didn't see that.
ROBERT KUBIS: --where
you have a big cannon,
and you can shoot your Cloud
Function into the cloud, which
is amazing.
So I encourage everybody also
to check out the Cloud Function
showcase in Moscone West.
MARK MANDEL: Actually,
it's worth noting,
you just talked about how
much time and effort goes
into the showcases, how
much time and effort
goes into your presentations,
but that's just one
showcase and one present--
we have over 500, 400
presentations, and how many
showcases on the show floor?
ROBERT KUBIS: I don't know--
60, 70, 80.
I don't know.
It's a lot.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so that's--
I mean, that's a lot of
effort is kind of my point
to put on a show this size
that's spanning, what,
six buildings?
MELANIE WARRICK: And
how many attendees?
I heard 20,000 or 25,000.
ROBERT KUBIS: 20,000, yeah,
something around that.
MELANIE WARRICK: And how does
this compare to last year?
ROBERT KUBIS: It
is actually-- so I
have been with cloud, in
particular with Google Cloud,
for three years and
four months now.
And I have experienced--
I think this is my fourth Next.
And it has been a
tremendous growth.
I think last year
around 7,000 to 10,000.
I don't know the exact number.
The year before that was 2,000.
So it basically tripled,
almost quadrupled, in size.
And now it doubled
in size again.
But it's just crazy.
It outgrew I/O this year,
it has been the biggest,
largest conference
for Google so far.
And from what I've seen, it's
amazing so far [INAUDIBLE]..
MARK MANDEL: And
this is my third Next
and this is the biggest.
But I actually genuinely
believe this is the best Next.
MELANIE WARRICK: And I know
you did the podcast last year.
Did you do it the
year before that too?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Wow.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I've been
doing the podcast on the show
floor for--
ROBERT KUBIS: The
third year now, right?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Third year, nice.
MARK MANDEL: We
didn't know what we
were getting into in that first
year, but still, here we are.
MELANIE WARRICK: Here we are.
MARK MANDEL: It's wonderful.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well,
Rob, anything else
you wanted to share with the
folks back home around Next,
around things they
should look for?
ROBERT KUBIS: I hope everybody
enjoys their experience here.
Please reach out to us
and the podcast team
if you have any questions.
Also, we love to hear positive
and critical feedback.
So if there is anything where
you think where we can improve,
please let us know.
But also show us the love,
basically, where we do well.
We want to hear that.
We need that as well
to basically find
the energy to do even better
Next for you next year.
And follow me on
Twitter at @hostirosti.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MELANIE WARRICK: Are you
speaking anywhere anytime soon
outside of Next?
ROBERT KUBIS: So I think I
take a break for a while.
MARK MANDEL: That
seems reasonable.
MELANIE WARRICK: That
seems acceptable.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Robert, thank you so
much for joining us.
ROBERT KUBIS: Thank
you for having me.
MARK MANDEL: All right.
ROBERT KUBIS: Cheers.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thanks,
again, for everybody
who came out for today,
as well as everyone
has come for the last two days.
We've really appreciated
being able to talk
to different partners
and students and--
MARK MANDEL: Alliance people--
the older relationships--
MELANIE WARRICK: Some
of our own colleagues,
just getting a sense
of the perspectives
and the interest
and what everybody
has been experiencing.
We appreciate that.
I also want to just take
a second and say this,
because this is my first
Next for the podcast.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And I know, Mark, we
were talking about
it before offline
that this is your third one.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
you and [? Frances ?]
did this last year
and the year before.
So this is like old hat for you.
MARK MANDEL: Totally.
MELANIE WARRICK: But
I'm going to say,
one of the things
that I've observed
that has been really impressive
is just how many people have
come by.
And I'm really
grateful for that,
for the listeners who have
stopped by to say thank you.
So thank you for
saying thank you,
because that means a
lot to hear that this
has been very helpful for you.
And I also want to
give a shout out
to James, who's been with us
for a while, who's been helping
to edit this podcast.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, my god, yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK:
He's been incredible,
especially with what we've
been doing for this week.
And more recently, Jennifer
and Trey, who have been also
incredible.
So we're not just doing
this by ourselves.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely not.
MELANIE WARRICK: We have
a couple of other people
who have been phenomenal
and making sure
that this actually
is getting done.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, they
have been killing it.
Doing daily episodes
is super hard work.
And setting all of the
interviews and everything
we've been doing at Next,
it's been like nonstop
while we've been here.
But we couldn't have done
it without the support
of all the people behind us.
So thanks.
Yeah, big thanks to them.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank
you very, very much.
And then, Mark, thanks
for making this so easy.
This has been fantastic.
And bringing me
along for the ride.
I really appreciate it.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you for joining me.
This has been an absolute
delight and a pleasure.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
I think that's a
wrap for us for Next.
And we will have another
episode, like always,
next week.
You will get to hear
about container security,
to give out a little tee-up.
But yeah.
Outside of that, Mark,
you going anywhere,
you're going to do anything?
MARK MANDEL: Sleep.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: I'm going to sleep.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Sleeping is good.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
[LAUGHS] Need to recover.
MARK MANDEL: You too?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
I definitely need to recover.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
No, it's been a great event.
Thank you all for listening.
And yeah, we'll actually
see you all next week.
MELANIE WARRICK: We'll
see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]